[Music]
you say you're turning 60 you do not
appear to age in any way and i'm not
just flattering you i would say this
behind your back as well among some
other things but you do not
you do not seem to age are you falling
apart in any way no a while ago a year
ago i said geez i'm awful smooth right
right here have i lost hair did i used
to have hair there and i asked i said i
asked a friend you said oh no if you're
if you get to a certain age maybe your
pants kind of uh you know kind of rub it
away and then somebody else said i asked
somebody they said oh no jeff you're
getting older older men if you're older
you lose that look at that never heard
that you you didn't all i'm noticing is
that you have a different flesh tone
than i do look at that well
look at these two together put them
together
look at that right well don't touch them
[Applause]
now you go with the black sock you go
with the dressy black sock who are you
you're the
anyway you're doing very well on the
hair i think i've got tons of